[Music]
you and ambassador Nikki Haley's
surprised almost everybody washed him
yesterday by announcing her resignation
she can keep a secret learn that ever
since there's been a lot of talk about
who want to replace her and one of the
names we've heard most is that a Deena
Powell she served as a White House
adviser until the beginning of this year
Powell seems like a nice person lots of
people like her is she the right person
for the job that's the question
well she's worked on behalf of virtually
every idea that President Trump ran
against in his 2016 campaign Trump you
remember said it was time for America to
act on its own behalf for once
internationally and to avoid pointless
and counterproductive Wars are those
Tina Powell's views they are not before
joining the Trump administration she was
a partner at Goldman Sachs she was
president of the Goldman Sachs
foundation that's the nonprofit arm of
the investment bank while there she
worked extensively with another famous
foundation the Clinton Foundation and
they worked together on various goals
that most Trump voters would find
repugnant at a Clinton Global Initiative
event for example Powell shared the
stage with Bill Clinton they discussed
how to meet quote global challenges with
quote corporate solutions Powell is a
close friend with Obama consigliere
Valerie Jarrett as well as with
left-wing buffoon Arianna Huffington
it's not guilt by association but you
should know that President Trump is
fighting to restrict immigration from
dangerous countries but while working
for the Bush administration Powell
boasted that 90% of student visas were
being granted within a week even for
students from countries that hate the
United States
she also once said that a major flaw in
American diplomacy to the Islamic world
is that we talk too much and we need to
quote listen more doesn't make her a bad
person it does make her exactly the sort
of person George W Bush might appoint as
UN Ambassador and in this context that's
not a compliment maybe she got the job
anyway you never know the confirmation
hearings ought to be interesting if she
does because we'll get to hear a lot
more in much greater detail about how
Goldman Sachs actually works and that'll
be an education we'll keep you posted